walkism is the greatest enemy black
america has ever had
outside of slavery itself
there's nothing worse that could happen
because you're doing all these things in
our name
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bringing to you the issues and
awareness that you need to know about
the violence on the south side of
chicago but also to raise as much money
as possible to build a community center
on this much needed block called o block
it's called o block because it's named
after a young man named od perry who was
shot and killed the gangs took the o in
his name and start calling it o block
well we decided we like the o but we're
going to change it to opportunity block
i want to thank fox for giving me the
opportunity every single day to bring to
you rooftop revelations where i share
with you my thoughts viewpoints and
opinions on matters as it relates to
violence in chicago and issues
that impact us across our great country
we are going through a battle over
wokism in america most of these debates
are taking place in elite circles like
academia and corporations and
universities
as is usually the case no one ever comes
to communities like ours
and asks us how this cultural war
affects us
what
what they never talk to us about what we
feel and how we think things are going
on
and our take on it and i'm so glad to
have with us shelby steele to talk about
that very issue today mr steele thank
you for being on the show
well thank you so much for having me
absolutely i want to jump right in i
want to ask you a question about this
wokism thing you know what do you make
about all the woke-ism
what is the real story uh behind the
battle and why do you think
these woke folks
claim to be helping us i know that's a
lot to unpackage but if you could just
go over it i would greatly appreciate it
well i'll try and do my best um
i think woke-ism comes
from a larger phenomenon uh white guilt
america did i think in the mid 60s the
bravest thing any nation i'm aware of in
history has ever done which is to admit
that it partook
of evil
and it partook of evil for four
centuries
wasn't just a quick minute
and then it held on for as long as it
really could to that that evil of racism
and bigotry
well you don't then finally come to
confess that when you uh without there
being
a consequence
and one of the consequences is
that the moral authority of the american
democracy
was put at risk
because of this history of evil that
came to the forefront
uh in the sick in the 60s
since that time
white america understandably
has been trying to re-establish its
moral
authority its moral legitimacy
[Music]
and in order to do that
it had it has to find ways to
demonstrate
that it is not guilty any longer of
those old evils those old sins is free
and it therefore has moral legitimacy
and our democracy
is
is a legitimate democracy and that we're
good people and so on well wilkism just
simply is the spinning out of that guilt
so today you know the president of the
united states says he has to appoint to
the supreme court of black woman
an hispanic woman not a
white woman that's old hat
he has to now show his
innocence
of racism
by appointing a black woman so who the
woman is none of us know
what the qualifications are none of us
so and he in a sense he he bends the
rules
in order to look innocent of the past
well localism is the corruption
it is very specifically the woke-ism is
is corrupt because we'll be more
interested
in retrieving the white the innocence of
of white america
than it is in the development of black
america
and so we as blacks even though whites
are now saying look we do this and we do
this and we give you this and we give
you that and so forth
and yet we're over here falling farther
and farther behind
ukraine the whites claim that they're
safe they're helping us they're saving
us they've got affirmative action
they've got diversity they've got
inclusion that you name it
we're falling farther and farther and
further behind black family right today
is shattered
from its dependency on white guilt
and unworking bookism is the greatest
enemy black america has ever had
outside of slavery itself
there's nothing worse that could happen
because you're doing all these things in
our name
and when uh you know you look at
the advertising and corporations of
universities
uh safe spaces for black students
affiliated dormitory i mean it's just
it's it's tragic that we're just
consumed
white america is just consumed with this
idea this need to be innocent of racism
there's no way you can change what
happened on the planet
my father was injured by it was injured
by it there's no way you can you can fix
that you need to leave us alone at this
point
quote
frederick douglass
yeah how to help blacks
in america after the civil war his
answer was
leave us alone
yeah i agree 100 you know i'm hearing
many of the principles that you talk
about in your books like hard work and
wood shedding and personal
responsibility and
and so on as being described as vestiges
of
white supremacy
why has the left
tried so hard to destroy these ideas as
vestiges of white supremacy
because they don't believe in black
people
they don't believe that we can they
really do in a sense believe we're
inferior
[Music]
and they make public policy around that
inferiority
and so they incense enable it they they
encourage it the more there's blacks
can't fail enough for them
the more tragedy and so forth that black
that blacks have to live with
the more innocent they are because they
can come up with another program another
uh
another what i call poetic truth another
series of narratives and stories and
lies
uh that reflect their innocence and how
pitiful we are what what liberals what
liberals will not do is stand toe-to-toe
with a black person and say why don't
you take responsibility for yourself
yeah
yeah
you know mr st i want to ask you a
question why is it then that why do you
why are you so passionate and why do you
believe in these american principles so
much
because i'm an american
deep in my heart i'm an american and i
believe america has
the american democracy is the best
conception for our society
imaginable that
that we represent a step forward in
human evolution
our the idea of the individual being
able to
uh being a citizen and responsible for a
in a democratic society as opposed to
uh autocracies and so forth it is a
beautiful beautiful thing and is is the
best way road for all of us the the
catchings
you have to take responsibility for
yourself that ethic prevails all across
america
uh white black otherwise uh
responsibility
is freedom
[Music]
yeah you know mr joe i want to ask you
this last question you know when we
think about walkism do you think
uh walkism
if successful
will finish off the job of post-60
liberalism
will it and will it be the death of us
uh
that word is not too strong
it's killing us now it's killing us now
uh
i you know i i i say every day i i hope
that that white somehow begin to get the
message begin to to to
stop this this notion that your
benevolence your your virtue signaling
is somehow going to help black america
achieve equality in american life the
opposite is true it's going to keep us
down
you che you reduce the standards
everywhere blacks appear to enter want
to enter society you reduce the
standards thereby saying we have no
faith in you you're inferior
we'll suspend the s.a.t exam in
universities and we won't count it
anymore because blacks don't do well on
it
what
who
no segregationist insulted me more than
that
i i
it
it is a a sense that we just would just
put a pity case that makes you always
have to drag along behind me
uh
and and there's no way around that
there's no way you can
whether you like me or whether you don't
there's just no way you can you can
dance around that we either stand up
like men and women and take our place in
this world or we don't
absolutely
well mr steele as always
it's been a tremendous blessing to have
you on
you are a blessing to america and a
tremendous blessing in my life and i
want to thank you personally uh for
sharing your thoughts and viewpoints and
opinions and
being so passionate about black
conservatism and sharing it with the
world uh thank you so much
well
double that back at you thank you so
much for everything you do you have a
special place in god's eye i can tell
you that you're a good man thank you so
much thank you as always i want to say
thank you to eli steele for producing
our show thank you to terrell for
filming it in this cold cold weather
and
my gratitude and applause cannot go out
enough to fox for giving me this
platform every single day to bring to
you rooftop revelations i am extremely
thankful and grateful for this
opportunity as i always say god bless
you
god bless america
thank you for another rooftop revelation
and until tomorrow
peace
you